-This is a story --
"Wine Country." You directed it.
You're one of the stars in it,
and it is a story of six women
going to Napa
for a birthday party.
And it is a -- the six --
the core six, which are you,
Ana Gasteyer, Maya Rudolph
Paula Pell, Emily Spivey, and --
-Rachel Dratch.
And then also,
Tina Fey's in the film.
-Yes.
-And it is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There are so many funny moments
and there are
so many emotional moments.
I found myself getting
very choked up
during even the funny moments.
-But you love to cry.
-I do love to cry.
[ Laughter ]
I love to cry.
And I love to cry
when I'm happy.
-Me too. Me too.
-I'm just saying,
the moments where you guys
were being yourselves --
'cause everybody is kind o
playing a version --
-That's right.
-Yeah.
-There's not a lot of
acting in there.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's not a documentary
-But I was getting choked up
thinking of how lucky I wa
to have spent that much time
with these incredibly
talented people.
And it is inspired by
an actual trip, yeah?
-Yeah, we took Dratch
to wine country for her 50th
and then we went to Ana's --
for Ana's birthday,
we went to Palm Springs.
We kind of smashed
some of those trips together
and then, you know,
used creative license
to write other things
that didn't happen.
-I remember one of my favorite
stories is you --
on the flight to the first one
you lost your phone
on the plane.
-Okay.
So, I like to plan things,
and I think I'm good at it
And so I had basically
the entire trip's itinerar
on my phone.
And then I went in -- and do you
guys -- when you use --
when you put your phone
in your back pocket
and sometimes you go to
the bathroom on the airplane
and you pull your pants down
you know sometimes --
Yes, right?
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "Did I -- did I --"
and so, I flushed the toilet
and I was washing my hands
'cause I wash my hands.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like --
I looked for my phone,
and I was like, "Oh, my God.
I flushed my phone
down the toilet."
And I came out. And this is --
When I screw up,
I get really mad.
-Yeah.
-And so I'm like, "I flushed
my phone down the toilet!"
[ Laughter ]
And everyone was like, "What?"
And I was like, "I flushed
my phone down the toilet,
and the trip is ruined and all
of the plans are ruined."
And I just sat there and jus
like huffed and puffed.
And I was like,
"And everything is ruined
and it's not gonna be
a good time."
And everyone's like,
"What's happening?"
And everybody acted exactly ho
you would think they would act
Maya Rudolph, the Earth mother
like, big-hearted, was like,
"Get me some gloves.
I'm gonna look in that toilet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ana Gasteyer,
level-headed, was like,
"You know,
maybe it's in your bag."
And I was like, "No.
It's down the toilet."
[ Laughter ]
Paula Pell, forever supportive
was like,
"I need a new phone, too."
[ Laughter ]
"So when we land,
we'll both go buy new phones."
[ Laughter ]
And then Emily Spivey,
who is the most hilarious
in times of crisis,
was just looking out the window,
drinking her wine going, "Y'all,
this is my worst nightmare."
[ Laughter ]
"If my phone went in the toilet,
y'all, I would die."
And then it was in my bag.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was in my bag.